es ist die größte maschine der welt und
es ist damit nicht nur europas größte
baustelle sondern auch eines der größten
experimente die je von menschenhand
erschaffen wurden die rede ist vom
internationalen fusionsreaktor iter und
der reaktor könnte bald einsatzbereit
sein damit würde tatsächlich die zukunft
beginnen oder ist es schon zu spät um
damit den klimawandel aufzuhalten krieg
zum science fiction gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen kernfusionstechnik
funktioniert nach dem großen vorbild der
sonne und so könnte ein kern
fusionskraftwerk eine unmenge an energie
produzieren und zwar umweltverträglich
sauberen strom und das ohne von wind
sonne öl oder gas abhängig zu sein der
menschheit könnte so theoretisch eine
unerschöpfliche energiequelle
erschlossen werden manche hoffen damit
also auf die lösung für alle
energieprobleme unserer erde und so
funktioniert die kernfusion die
atomkerne von wasserstoff verschmelzen
unter sehr hohem druck und bei sehr
hoher temperatur miteinander im
gegensatz zur kernspaltung bilden
vereinfacht gesagt zwei leichte atome
ein schweres die gesamtmasse des neuen
atoms ist geringer als die der beiden
einzeln das was fehlt ist die
entstandene energie das muss man sich
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen ein
gramm der brennstoffe die wasserstoff
isotope tritium und deuterium könnten in
einem fusionsreaktor so viel energie
liefern wie sie bei der verbrennung von
elf tonnen kohle entsteht doch nicht nur
das dabei würde das klima nicht einmal
durch den ausstoß von co2 belastet ein
weiterer vorteil der ganze prozess ist
sehr viel ungefährlicher als die atom
spaltung in kernkraftwerken wie wir sie
heute kennen denn selbst bei einem
unfall setzt ein fusionsreaktor nicht
die unmengen an radioaktiver strahlung
frei wie ein kernkraftwerk einen super
gau also eine kernschmelze kann es nicht
geben wenn es einen unfall gibt bricht
der prozess komplett zusammen und zudem
haben die radioaktiven stoffe die
hierbei entstehen eine halbwertszeit von
jahrzehnten und eben nicht von
jahrmillionen so wie es eben bei einem
atomkraftwerk der fall ist doch es gibt
vor allem noch ein großes
wirtschaftliches problem bei der
kernfusionstechnik wie kann man es
schaffen
mehr energie aus dem fusionsprozess
herauszuholen als man hineinsteckt dazu
kommen die beiden folgenden
herausforderungen wie und wann wird des
forschungsteams gelingen einem
fusionskraftwerk einen plasma strom
dauerhaft brennen zu lassen
denn das ist der ort und dem wasserstoff
atome bei millionengrab fusionieren und
welches material lässt sich finden das
den krassen belastungen an der innenwand
des plasma gefäßes standhält zu einem
der vielversprechendsten projekte
weltweit gehört das internationale
fusionsprojekt etat das steht für
international firma nuclear experimente
reaktor die lateinische bedeutung ist
weg und vielleicht ist dieser weg
tatsächlich der richtige um erstmalig
mit einem fusionsprozess energie zu
gewinnen
doch noch handelt es sich um eine
baustelle die größte baustelle europas
so groß wie achtung 60 fußballfelder
liegt sie auf dem gelände des
französischen forschungszentrums karasch
an den fusionsreaktor in frankreich
arbeitet die halbe welt zusammen die
europäischen staaten zusammen mit
russland usa in den japan südkorea und
china
laut den verantwortlichen geht der bau
der anlage jetzt in die finale phase
dazu etat sprecherin sabine götz im
golem interview das geht hier gerade
richtig voran momentan sind wir genau im
zeitplan
demnach soll 2025 die premiere
stattfinden ein plasma soll im reaktor
gezündet werden die 120 meter lange und
76 meter hohe halle für die ita maschine
ist gerade fertig gestellt worden
im november des vergangenen jahres wurde
der letzte beton gegossen und dann kam
das dach auf dem riesigen gelände kommen
jetzt purple noch weitere gebäude und
anlagen hinzu doch der großteil der
bauaufgaben ist bereits erledigt nämlich
70 technisch gesehen basiert etat auf
dem töpfermarkt prinzip das konzept des
dokr mark reaktors ist nicht neues wurde
1952 von zwei sowjetischen physikern in
moskau entwickelt nur kurze zeit später
wurden dann auch die ersten tag
experimente durchgeführt der begriff
zocker markt heißt übersetzt übrigens so
viel wie toro ideale kammer in
magnetspulen wobei die silbe talk auf
strom hindeutet und somit die
besonderheit des talker mark prinzips
hervorhebt dem stromfluss in plasma dass
man dem feld wird hier zum teil von eine
im plasma fließenden strom erzeugt das
konzept beim töpfermarkt basiert also
auf dem
genetischen einschluss ein plasma aus
wasserstoff isotope wird so auf etwa 100
bis 150 millionen grad erhitzt denn erst
dann würden die geladenen thorium und
tritium partikel die sich normalerweise
abstoßen verschmelzen sie fusionieren
dabei zu einem helium kern und einem
neutron ursprünglich sollte bereits 2018
wasserstoff plasma erzeugt werden doch
laut der etat verantwortliche wird dies
frühestens 2025 der fall sein erst dann
können dann auch die weiteren
experimente angegangen werden ab 2035
dann beispielsweise die experimente zum
deuterium und tritium gemischt doch auch
dieser meilenstein war eigentlich schon
für das jahr 2025 vorgesehen etat
basiert also auf dem magnetischen
einschluss doch charakteristisch bei
diesem projekt ist ein reifen förmiger
magnetfeld käfig wer das plasma deutlich
länger zusammenhalten soll so soll die
sogenannte energie einschluss zeit
optimiert werden und hier ist laut
ansicht vieler fachleute auf einem
wirklich guten weg allein schon wegen
seines enormen plasma volumens von
achtung 8 140 kubikmetern
damit ist etat im verhältnis von volumen
zur oberfläche absoluter spitzenreiter
ihr wisst umso größer das volumen um so
besser ist das verhältnis von oberfläche
zu inhalt also desto größer der inhalt
umso geringer ist die oberfläche pro
kubikzentimeter zum beispiel so sollen
verlust prozesse so gering wie möglich
gehalten werden in der letzten stufe
soll die trasse 500 megawatt fusions
leistung erzeugen
aber nicht nur der fusions leistungswert
an sich ist von großer bedeutung sondern
vor allem auch das verhältnis der
fusions leistung zur externen
heizleistung in diesem zusammenhang
wichtig der sogenannte q werthein
verstärkung faktor der bisherige rekord
liegt bei q gleich 0,7 also keine
verstärkung sondern energieverlust etat
soll den wert 10 erreichen womit das
erste mal ein wert größer als 1
realisiert würde also das erste mal
energie gewonnen werden würde dennoch
sind expertinnen und experten weltweit
nicht unbedingt optimistisch manche
kritikerinnen und kritiker befürchten
dass die kernfusion zu spät kommt so zum
beispiel die vorsitzende des
umweltausschusses im deutschen bundestag
sylvia kotting-uhl die in der grünen
bundestagsfraktion für kernfusion
zuständig ist zum einen sei nicht
absehbar ob die
musikalischen probleme in absehbarer
zeit gelöst werden können und es
überhaupt jemals einen energie
erzeugenden fusionsreaktor geben wird
zum anderen könnte es noch bis zum ende
des jahrhunderts dauern
dass die kernfusion wenn überhaupt einen
beitrag zur co2 freien stromerzeugung
liefern kann und ja falls das fusions
feuer in karaj 2035 gezündet werden
könnte wären wir zwar einen großen
schritt weiter das problem wäre aber
noch nicht gelöst den etat soll nur
demonstrieren dass kernfusion machbar
ist er ist sein nachfolger mit der
bezeichnung demo soll tatsächlich in
betrieb gehen und stromerzeugung und
zwar frühestens 2050 und natürlich auch
nur unter der voraussetzung dass etat
ein erfolg wird für die rettung der erde
vor dem klimawandel ist das vielleicht
zu spät das befürchtet beispielsweise
der vizepräsident des wuppertal
instituts für klima umwelt energie
manfred fischedick die globalen probleme
müssen bis 2050 gelöst werden
dafür kommt etat zu spät wenn bis dahin
die pariser klimaschutzziele nicht
erfüllt würden drohen seiner ansicht
nach zitat nicht mehr beherrschbare
veränderung des erdsystems etat kommt
demnach also zu spät denn 2050 könnten
vielleicht auch schon die erneuerbaren
energien die stromversorgung leisten und
somit die stromkosten fallen andere
kritikerinnen und kritiker bemängeln vor
allem die kosten des projekts die ganze
finanziellen mittel die bislang bereits
in die fusionsforschung geflossen sind
fehlen demnach an anderer stelle
beispielsweise in der forschung zur
energieeffizienz und -speicherung ganz
unberechtigt ist diese kritik nicht denn
die kosten für etat sind aus dem ruder
gelaufen und war vollkommen ursprünglich
waren einmal 5 milliarden euro
vorgesehen
das ist schon teurer als der large
hadron collider in genf am cern also der
größte teilchenbeschleuniger der welt
mittlerweile geht man von knapp 20
milliarden euro aus also noch mal vier
mal so teuer wie funktioniert kernfusion
diese frage beantwortet doktor watson
bei unserem wissenschafts netzwerkes
1054 er kommt nämlich regelmäßig in die
zukunft also anklicken anschauen und
unbedingt doktor watson abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran